Now, of all the feuds
Trump has going,
my favorite is his beef
with rapper Mac Miller.
Now, Mac made a song called
"Donald Trump" in 2011.
Trump initially...
he initially lauded the song.
The "Donald Trump" song
just hit over 20 million.
That's not so bad.
I'm very proud of that.
This kid is the new Eminem.
Is he doing an impression
of himself there?
Okay, so, however,
the song went platinum
and then Trump
threatened to sue Miller
for royalties
for use of his name.
So in turn, Mac Miller
denounced Trump,
telling his Twitter followers
"Just please don't
elect this (bleep) man."
All right?
This is true.
This is all true, right?
It's great. Okay. So...
Now, on one hand,
this is just Trump being Trump.
But on the other hand,
Mac Miller is here,
and he's pissed.
So please welcome
multiplatinum-selling rapper
and noted
Trump feud participant
Mac Miller, everybody!
-♪ ♪
-(cheering, whooping, applause)
Thank you, Larry.
I only have one thing to say.
I (bleep) hate you,
Donald Trump.
So you wanted to sue me,
but then you realized
you can't sue somebody
just for being super talented
and incredibly good-looking.
You-you say
you want
to make America great again,
but we all know
what that really means.
You know, ban Muslims,
Mexicans are rapists,
black lives don't matter.
Make America great again?
I think you want
to make America white again.
So I come here today,
as a white man,
with the hope
that maybe you'll listen to me.
In other words,
let me white-splain this to you,
you racist son of a bitch.
(cheering and applause)
You see, you're lowering the bar
for our nation's intelligence.
Your only goal
is to stay in the spotlight,
no matter how much
it fuels the fire of hate groups
that you apparently know nothing
about,
like, uh, the KKK and neo-Nazis.
You have people at your rallies
who openly assault
black teenage girls
because, hey, that's American.
The messed up thing is I don't
even really know if you're evil.
I think you're just such an
egomaniacal, attention-thirsty,
psychopathic, power-hungry,
delusional waste
of skin and bones that you'll...
that you'll...
that you'll do, say,
or allow anything
if it means you'll just get one
more minute in the limelight.
The thing is, it says more
about us as a country.
I guess we're finally showing
our true colors.
Not only are we letting
this (bleep) slide--
we're (bleep) supporting you.
And if we're stupid enough
to elect you,
I know exactly
what everyone's gonna say.
"I'm moving to Canada. I don't
want to live in a country
"where Donald Trump
is president.
I'm getting out of here."
You know what I'm-a do
if you get elected?
I'm staying right
the (bleep) here. That's right.
(cheering and applause)
♪ I'm not going anywhere ♪
I'm-a be here every day telling
the world how much I hate you,
how much of a clown you are, and
how we as a nation are better
than you will ever be
as a racist (bleep) of a human.
Because I love America,
and I'm never giving it up
to a troll like you, you bitch!